[Music]
in Zombie ready news it's not me are you
ready yes these fools are I got cans of
tuna and a lot of weapons submitted by
Jeff from Garden Grove Oh subject oh the
moon author in the crew I just say only
one country is currently ready to
survive a zombie apocalypse Korea why
are scientists studying this yeah every
time we have these articles is always
like a scientist system no you're like a
scientist got a grant to study what
would happen in a zombie apocalypse yeah
pressing things out there but that's
cool yeah which scientists did this
because they need to get their scientist
car taken the University of Phoenix
scientists mm-hmm they actually write
dissertations on this good it's a
Brazilian mathematicians they made their
math and they figured out that nice made
their math happen yeah that math
happened and they figured out that's
according to their standard models it
would require a minimum of forty seven
soldiers per 1000 citizens for a country
to survive if there was a zombie
apocalypse and there's only one country
that's prepared for that how do they
know how many zombies there's good how
do they know who's on D behavior so they
oh the behavior ones a good question but
the how many ones we would need they're
talking about like how like their
weapons training and like what weapons
they can get for so population versus
the soldiers yeah Russia but also
depends what every citizens have are
armed themselves though right there was
a lot of factors that they considering
they came down they boiled down to this
and what do you what does it mean
surviving does that mean no civilians
get hurt or does that mean just like the
leaders don't get hurt we're like the
least amount of people that would die
and that they could probably make it out
okay what is this high chance of
civilian survival you're guessing North
Korea any more guesses
based off those numbers I'm thinking for
Thea - I would say well America's pretty
good but I'm also like yay America yeah
I don't know if we have that ratio
though but maybe about that we have a
lot of nuclear weapon oh but that would
hurt civilians
I say North Korea where the what was the
gun problems that everyone wants to get
rid of guns so like yeah cuz like if we
could do so many mass shootings a year
in this country I'm pretty sure that we
could take on a zombie apocalypse yes a
one person with the capability of doing
a mass shooting took other guns and used
it for good
using America same air okay well let's
hear it then no so John Barr got it
right yeah yes I knew it because they
have 47 point for military personnel per
1000 people oh [ __ ]
and it for the u.s. it's four point two
active military person for Brazil is one
point six active why not run every
Russian grandma owns a [ __ ] automatic
weapon I don't understand that well a
going based off of the study it's just
ratio from military to citizen and North
Korea has the highest standing military
I mean for their country size zombies
would be civilians what if the zombies
were the military exactly then who would
have the highest chance yeah yeah North
Koreans can only fight a war for like
five minutes before the tired just the
way okay some [ __ ] to happen I don't
know like having extra food or water I
am prepared I'm coming over these
photons
emergency supplies those always prepared
we have guns and water how are you gonna
eat let us go over anywhere and I just
[ __ ] Baba [ __ ] ah that's what
the guns before I feel that's not nice
if you get an emergency kit you want to
make sure that it lasts about three days
because that's the typical rescue time
if there's a natural disaster like I say
there's a flood or something and then
you're stacking up I'm gonna want to be
able to survive for three days we have a
lot of Korean neighbors some for sure
gonna go another house
take all their punch on stuff cuz you
could eat kimchi for three days
ah what if you can't get to your supply
whoa that's fast like if you have a low
supply ready but you're like you guys to
come over and be like Oh Steve Haven and
then we're slowly gonna start killing
you guys and you guys I want to die
first
that was my thing that's my plan we
talked about this and it's gon be
apocalypse I I don't want to death by
zombie bite nah I want to just like want
to live a very like dystopian world
either just [ __ ] and meat exactly so
you three are dead oh we got food before
I would go to survive yeah you just have
to shrivel away slowly what deteriorate
I mean if I get the disease no if I get
the disease and I'm like alright well
kill me now
I could eat me I just I just request
that you saved my face that's the first
year we're cutting off and dispose it no
you're gonna keep it haven't you seen
Book of Eli yeah oh with that once you
go you can't turn back you cannot go to
cannibalism you can't do it it's gonna
change you know me once you become a
cannibal you can't go back to the ugh
you got to stay clean
well you cuz you get addicted to human
flesh I don't think I could eat a person
[Music]
you're starving I think you can eat
anything ate a dog no no I'm pretty
comfortable with the hungry feeling like
nobody's star before like not eat for
two weeks
childhood a bag of cockroaches just
eating those right and then you focus on
raising them and then and they're like
let's say you find a dead human on the
ground like movies and berries without
knowing that they're poisoned before I
eat a human you say this though there's
a lot of loquat trees all over Pasadena
oh my god you're so obsessed with that
[ __ ] yeah because they're all over it's
ridiculous how many there are like on
the scale of class
what's a loquat tree look what that
furry or yellow thing it's an orange
it's like an orange big seeds and they
call it a Japanese plum - it's the first
fruiting fruit of this
in the year so they'll fruit around like
January February and even March but
you'll see the pall over Elliot Pasadena
and so that the market it's all yeah I
don't work in people's backyards yeah so
it's not a kumquat no no clock its ya
saben had one you know what's our Roy's
right yeah it's pretty bomb button
that's all I snack on when I go for my
walks he's picking off the team
and like people are looking at me like
I'm done I'm like these are [ __ ]
expensive this snacking while you're
exercising it's pretty awesome
it's for water I want to do that like
what just live in the forest I know you
do just live out there for a minute
because I want to experiment and see
what will happen to my body if I just
drink water and eat whatever the hell I
caught and cooked yeah like what will
happen oh you'd beat oh yeah D'Arcy
survivor everybody comes back with like
looking words no they look hi parasites
yeah they come back bingo ABS though
you'll catch a bug in it is yeah hell
yeah I don't want to do it that hardcore
but no if you watch videos on YouTube
there's guys out there that will just be
like 3-month bushwhack challenge or
whatever that it's called bushwhacking
that's a long time yeah makes me think
of your Bush like your Bush no they
build shelter out of like mmm just
whatever and then they they set up traps
and they just know how to live out there
they have tools though I like shower
stuff dude I would die immediately now
they do it in the snow too they'll be
like winter bushwhacking there's this
guy that made like a den and then he
covered it with like there's this
covered in snow but it's just like a
dirt dam and it's an igloo yeah it's
like dirt igloo do to be a vault for a
reason for a survival like we literally
evolved societies to have higher chances
of survival yeah yeah no we just live in
our houses that we evolved to I just
want to try it though like cuz if you
tried that and then you come back home
imagine how much more you would
appreciate your home I
I'd be overwhelmed by all of this stuff
going on like oh that sounds yeah you
get desensitized by being around all of
it all the time but if you're like in
the woods and then you come back to that
you're just like holy [ __ ] there's too
much simulation everywhere you probably
go to a small town don't feel like New
York you start hearing every noise yeah
can you imagine how good your senses
would be to good if you have 10 people
attacking you you could be like
blindfolded and like know how to fight
we haven't even God can't be dead we
should just start with that oh yeah I've
got no camping yep you guys camp right
or did you just go out to shoot we just
went out to shoot but I love camping all
kinds of camp luxurious camping with the
capital on TV or that glamping now
bullshitting behind a bush with no
running water I'm done with that too I
rather just have an RV yeah keeps me
we're talking about getting an RV
no but I would not any time soon but
like eventually there's this thing
called a Sprinter van and you can
convert them to do all kinds of [ __ ] I
sent her a link I was like I know our
next family car she said know it to me
but it's [ __ ] doe a sprinter van is
basically a Honda Element no it's not
I'll show you a picture right after we
cut it's [ __ ] sick we could rat will
show you a picture right after we cut of
a Honda Element get up I when you buy it
it's a bug out here
[Laughter]
[Music]